&gt;&gt; He's decided that the best way to solve the slingshot sign problem is to use
math. If he can come up with an equation describing the trajectory of a ball
that makes it through the hoop, he'll be able to find every single point that
the ball has to pass through to get there. And this will tell him exactly where
not to hang his lovely new sign. If we call the horizontal position of the ball
at any given time x, and we call its vertical position at the same time y, then
here's a list of the x and y values of the ball at different points throughout
its trajectory. If we think of the space above the ground at Grant's display
booth as an x y coordinate plane, where x is horizontal and y is vertical, then
these are just the points that the ball passes through on its way to the hoop.
Looking at the coordinates of these points, do you think that we can find a
linear equation that goes through all them? Please answer yes or no.